und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und bettina schausten und abends
es geht ums geld die ganze woche im
bundestag wo ein haushaltsentwurf mit
milliardenschulden zur debatte steht der
bundesfinanzminister christian lindner
hatte bereits gestern abend hier im
heute-journal beteuert dass bleibe eine
ausnahme er sich hätte zudem entlastung
für die bürger zu beispiel tank rabatt
der ab morgen gilt aber wohl noch keine
wirkung entfalten dürfte entlasten will
die bürger auch der arbeitsminister
hubertus heil seine idee eines sozialen
klima geldes lehnt lindner allerdings
kategorisch ab wer daraus noch was außer
neuem streit in der ampelkoalition
daniel tanzen
es ist nicht leicht in diesen tagen
beides auseinanderzuhalten den
langfristigen plan der regierung und ihr
kurzfristiges krisenmanagement beispiel
entlastung bei energiepreisen
kurzfristig hatte die regierung hierzu
im märz ein zweites entlastungs paket
geschnürt das ab morgen in teilen greift
mit sprit preissenkung und neun euro
ticket es war ein kompromiss
langfristig war derweil ein klima geld
verabredet auf dass sich nun der
arbeitsminister bezieht ich weiß noch
mal daraufhin das klima geld und auch
das bürgergeld sind teil des
koalitionsvertrages deshalb ist es nicht
nur richtig dass wir das umsetzen dafür
gibt es auch eine politische grundlage
im koalitionsvertrag ist von klima geld
die rede allerdings als kompensation für
den co2 emissionshandel um dort einen
künftigen preiseinstieg zu kompensieren
und die akzeptanz des markts systems zu
gewährleisten heißt es hier werden wir
einen sozialen kompensationsmechanismus
entwickeln das klima geld heil will nun
nicht auf diesen künftigen co2
preisanstieg warten sondern schon ab 11
nächsten jahres ein klima geld auszahlen
an alleinstehende mit bis zu 4000 euro
bruttoverdienst und dann verheiratete
bis 1000 euro das problem der
finanzminister will das nicht herr heil
möchte jetzt allgemeine umverteilung mit
haushaltsmitteln machen und da gibt es
bessere wege der erste weg heißt lohn
und einkommenssteuer reform der zweite
weg heißt grundsicherung anpassen an die
inflation damit bedürftige menschen
nicht unter die räder kommen bei der
haushaltsdebatte heute gab es aus der
opposition unterschiedliche kritik mit
gemeinsamem nenner es gehe zu langsam
die union etwa forderte der
finanzminister müsse insgesamt schneller
entlasten angesichts seiner
mehreinnahmen durch inflation und kalte
progression sie werden reichlich
mehreinnahmen haben und ich sage ihnen
ganz ehrlich wir erwarten von ihnen
nicht dass die gönnerhafte irgendetwas
zurückgeben aber wir erwarten von ihnen
dass sie den menschen das zurückgeben
was ihnen vorher höhere steuern und
abgaben aus der tasche gezogen haben das
muss sein auch die linke man mehr tempo
an mit anderen fokus auf jene mit
weniger geld
bezahlen sollen wo viele nicht wissen
wie sie die gasrechnungen bezahlen soll
oder die immer weiter steigenden mieten
da ist es doch so dringend notwendig die
kleinen und mittleren einkommen diese
menschen zu entlasten die forderungen
von außen sind derweil das womöglich
kleinste problem der ampel bei aller
harmonie zu beginn zeigt sich nun die
größe die aufgaben desto tiefer manche
interne trendlinie
das ist ein wagnis würde aber china von
anfang an klar
die zeitenwende kostet viel öffentliche
haushalte und jeden einzelnen von uns
der preis um putin zu stoppen das von
der eu verhängte öl-embargo soll auch
wenn es kein vollständiges ist russland
stark treffen so die hoffnung in brüssel
ein kompromiss war das letzte nacht
schwer genug der nun kurzfristig
allerdings erstmal die ölpreise nach
oben treibt und damit die sorgen vor
weiter steigender inflation bei 8,1
prozent liegt die nun im euroraum wir
wollen uns die zusammenhänge gleich
genauer vor augen führen zunächst anne
gellinek mit der gipfel bilanz aus
brüssel
das ist gerade noch mal gut geht die
erleichterung ist nicht gespielt nach
vier wochen plus einem langen abend ist
das eu sanktionspaket beschlossen freude
auch weil der gipfel knapp am scheitern
vorbeigeschrammt ist europa hat sich
noch einmal zusammengerauft und ist von
sich selbst überrascht
nach langen diskussionen gestern haben
wir uns endlich geeinigt das hätte ich
nicht gedacht als wir rein ging sah es
nicht gut aus aber alle haben sich
konstruktiv verhalten und so konnten wir
einen kompromiss erreichen
alle außer einem viktor orban europas
oder querulant spielt nicht mit und
triumphiert noch gestern nacht schickt
der ein sieger video nach hause
ungarische familien können jetzt wieder
ruhig schlafen sagt er die perverse
ssten ideen sind abgewendet unter
perversen ideen versteht orban einen
lieferstopp für russisches öl nach
ungarn von dem sein land nun für eine
unbegrenzte zeit ausgenommen ist der
kanzler verteidigt den kompromiss das
war wichtig weil die übergangsmaßnahmen
die diese länder zu treffen haben nicht
so schnell haben abgeschlossen werden
können und weil es dann auf diese weise
auch möglich war eine gemeinsame
entscheidung zustande zu bringen und so
sieht die gemeinsame entscheidung aus ab
ende des jahres darf kein russisches öl
mehr auf dem seeweg in die eu
transportiert werden weiterhin geöffnet
bleibt aber die druschba pipeline um
ungarn die slowakei und tschechien zu
versorgen die auf russisches öl
angewiesen sind polen und deutschland
die am nord arm der pipeline hängen
steigen dagegen zum jahresende
freiwillig aus russischem öl aus das
zähe ringen um das öl embargo offenbart
auch die risse in europa kein
regierungschef traut sich vom gipfel
neue zumutungen für seine bürger
mitzubringen bei den sanktionen geht es
wirklich ans eingemachte
das ist der grösste export artikel
russlands ist der der auch am
attraktivsten für für weltweite käufer
ist und dass man das so lange heraus
geschoben hat sich mit energie
sanktionen und insbesondere sanktionen
beschäftigen ist nicht ohne grund so
deswegen war das jetzt auch so schwierig
ich würde jetzt auch noch erwarten dass
wir das wären 7 das paket sehr schnell
sehen was ich würde eher erwarten dass
es jetzt eine gewisse pause geben wird
in dieser in der sanktionierung der
ukraine krieg fordert viel von der eu
vielleicht mehr als sie im moment
liefern kann der zusammenhalt wird
schwieriger das ist die botschaft dieses
gipfels
öl-embargo steigende energiepreise
inflation und entlastungs paket das sind
themen für den präsidenten des ifo
instituts clemens fuß zum guten abend
gute nacht erschossen professor fuß
zunächst zu den folgen des ölembargos
schadet es ihrer meinung nach putin
wirklich oder wird weiter seine
staatskasse gefüllt dafür gehen hier die
ölpreise erst mal ordentlich in die höhe
das wird putin nicht besonders schaden
er kann sein öl auch woanders verkaufen
da muss er sich etwas umorganisieren
aber er kann das öl leicht apfel den
tanker es gibt ja genug kapazitäten das
öl embargo ist ja auch nicht komplett
das wird ihm nicht besonders schaden bei
uns kann es regional zu knappheiten
kommen und der ölpreis steigt insgesamt
natürlich schon aber das wird meines
erachtens nicht so dramatisch
die in diese sanktion kostet also uns
nicht so wahnsinnig viel aber sie bringt
auch wenig weil sie putin kaum schaden
der chef der internationalen
energieagentur der warnt vor engpässen
bei der spritversorgung in diesem sommer
auf den ölmärkten könnte es eng werden
befürchten sie dass auch
ja das halte ich für unwahrscheinlich
das kann vielleicht regional mal
passieren dort wo man jetzt viel
russisches öl gekauft hat aber öl kann
man relativ leicht umleiten und auch
relativ leicht transportieren das heißt
im sommer glaube ich nicht dass das
combat es können sich auch alle darauf
vorbereiten die hohen energiepreise das
jedenfalls sieht man schon treiben ja
die inflation jetzt soll der tank rabatt
der regierung der ab mitternacht ja in
kraft tritt für entlastungen bei den
bürgern sorgen also ist das eine
richtige maßnahme
ich halte das für eine falsche maßnahme
zum einen ist öl knapp das heißt wir
müssen alle öl sparen benzin sparen da
geben wir aber das signal das man eher
mehr verbraucht und da muss man sagen
haushalte mit hohem einkommen die haben
große autos die fahren mehr und
verbrauchen viel mehr benzin als
haushalte mit niedrigen einkommen die
die entlastung er brauchen das heißt
tank rabatt ist umverteilung von unten
nach oben die verteilungs effekte sind
also schlecht es ist insgesamt
ziemlicher quatsch
abgesehen von der tauglichkeit die sie
also offenkundig anzweifeln wird der
rabatt eigentlich überhaupt greifen
jedenfalls ja offenkundig noch nicht ab
sofort ab morgen und warum eigentlich
nicht
ja die frage ist ob die steuer senken an
die kunden weitergegeben wird wir hatten
ja kürzlich die mehrwertsteuersenkung
für sechs monate in der krise und da
haben wir gesehen dass etwa ein drittel
in die kassen der anbieter geflossen ist
also in die kassen der mineralölkonzerne
über die drei monate werden drei
milliarden ausgegeben für diesen tank
rabatt eine milliarde geht wenn das so
genau so läuft an die anbieter also an
die mineralölkonzerne ist ein weiterer
grund warum das nicht so viel bringt
wenn sie jetzt sagen besser nicht in
preise eingreifen das tut ja der staat
in diesem fall sondern gezielt niedriger
einkommen unterstützen ist dann dieses
klima geld von hubertus heil über das
wir anfänglich berichtet haben ein
richtiges instrument aus ihrer sicht
ich würde eher sagen dass so was wie der
kinderbonus ein richtiges instrument ist
beim klima geld geht es hier eher um die
langfristigen auswirkungen steigender
preise für fossile energieträger da muss
man warten ob die politik überhaupt erst
mal die preise erhöht also das ist etwas
früh aber im prinzip ist es richtig auch
in der aktuellen lage lieber gezielt
haushalten helfen die stark betroffen
sind vielleicht auch unternehmen
mittelständischen unternehmen die sehr
viel benzin verbrauchen aber nichts mit
in preise eingreifen sondern eben eher
transfers an diese gruppen gezielte
transfers vielleicht auch an fernpendler
teilweise hat die regierung dass sie
auch gemacht
nochmal zur inflation vielleicht zum
schluss rund acht prozent wie wird sich
das bis ende des jahres entwickeln
ja das hängt stark vom verlauf des
krieges ab es ist zu befürchten dass das
nochmal in die höhe gehen könnte wenn es
ein gas embargo gibt gegen russland auch
das wird ja diskutiert wenn es dazu
nicht kommt kann man damit rechnen dass
wir jetzt vielleicht langsam den
höhepunkt der inflation sehen es gibt
aber sehr viel unsicherheit eine rolle
spielt auch ob in china die lockdown
maßnahmen vielleicht ausgeweitet werden
und dann lieferungen ausfallen die
lieferketten probleme wenn die sich
verschlimmern dann kann es auch bei der
inflation noch mal schlimmer werden also
viele unsicherheiten bleiben noch das
war der präsident des ifo-instituts
clemens fuß schön dank nach münchen
vielen dank für
das gespräch haben wir vor der sendung
aufgezeichnet wenn wir hier über
folgekosten des krieges sprechen müssen
wir dorthin schauen wo die auswirkungen
um ein vielfaches dramatischer sind nach
afrika der eu-gipfel sagte der
afrikanischen union heute hilfe zu um
getreideexporte aus der ukraine
die von russland blockiert werden auf
anderen wegen zu ermöglichen doch es
geht nicht nur um weizen und dünger was
nun auch ausbleibt sind hilfsgelder
länder wie kenia oder somalia die von
extremer dürre betroffen sind sind
darauf dringend angewiesen unsere afrika
korrespondentin susann von jetzt
berichtet
anastasia marubeni griff für ihre
zukunft und die ihrer kinder und
enkelkinder die 50 jährige im
kenianischen u bahn bau zusammen mit
anderen gemeindemitgliedern einen sand
am meer soll in regenzeiten wasser unter
der erde speichern und so in dürrezeiten
eine art vorratsdaten bilden
die dürre in unserer gegend war
furchtbar sie war hart wir mussten lange
strecken zum wasserholen zurücklegen
also haben wir überlegt wie können wir
hier lange leben bleiben sand dämme
bauen um wasser in unserer gegend zu
bewahren
der santa monica ist nur ein projekt der
dresdner hilfsorganisation arche nova
die initiative ist international tätig
wird wesentlich von öffentlichen und
privaten geldern aus deutschland
unterstützt doch seit ausbruch des
krieges in der ukraine liegen projekte
in afrika auf eis
bisher haben wir die informationen
erhalten dass der ukraine priorität
eingeräumt wird dies wird sich also
definitiv auf die finanzierung in krina
und anderen ländern auswirken aber der
bedarf hier ist genauso groß
seit monaten warnen auch die großen
hilfsorganisationen vor einer
humanitären katastrophe in ostafrika
besonders hart trifft es die nord
kenianische region turkana der weltweite
anstieg der preise sowie anhaltende
dürre machen die arbeit hier immer
schwieriger hinzu aber kommt nun dass
hilfsgelder vermehrt in die ukraine
fließen
die aufmerksamkeit der welt ist anderswo
und wir wissen das aber
das elend der welt hat turkana nicht
verlassen und der regen der welt ist
nicht nach turkana gekommen
wir haben vier wegen ausfälle in folge
gesehen und wir fürchten einen fünften
führen auch in somalia fürchten sie eine
hungersnot schlimmer als die von 2011
damals verloren mehr als eine viertel
millionen menschen ihr leben wenn nicht
bald etwas passiere so oxfam werde in
den dürreregionen ostafrikas alle 48
sekunden ein mensch sterben wir haben
einen hilfsaufruf über 4,4 milliarden
dollar erhalten aber leider sind bisher
nur vier prozent davon finanziert und
das hat vor allem damit zu tun dass die
welt andere orte im blick hat und die
hungerkrise in ostafrika erhält nicht
die aufmerksamkeit die sie braucht
anastasia und die menschen im
kenianischen user haben glück gehabt ihr
sand damm war bereits vor dem ukraine
krieg finanziert viele nachbargemeinden
aber müssen warten und das könnte den
kampf ums wasser in der region
verschärfen
ja kriegsfolgen in afrika auf den
verlauf der kämpfe in der ukraine zumal
im donnerstagen wir jetzt in den
nachrichten gundula gause an diesem 97
kriegstag haben russische truppen ihre
angriffe auf den don was im osten der
ukraine unvermindert fortgesetzt um die
strategisch wichtige stadt serie unter
netz zu erobern sind auch die kämpfer
des putin treuen tschetschenen führer
skandiert im einsatz sie zeigen diese
bilder ihres einmarsch und sprechen auf
dem eigenen telegramm kanal von erfolgen
und auch der ukrainische gouverneur
gestand ein mittlerweile sei der größte
teil der stadt unter russischer
kontrolle verbliebene zivilisten
versuchen verzweifelt zu fliehen
die ukraine hat nach drei monaten
russischen angriffskrieg in mehr als
15.000 fällen ermittlungen wegen
kriegsverbrechen eingeleitet allerdings
sind nur 80 verdächtige in gewahrsam
zwei russische soldaten wurden in der
ukraine jetzt zu haftstrafen von elf
eineinhalb jahren verurteilt wegen
raketenangriffen auf zivile
einrichtungen
die soldaten hatten sich schuldig
bekannt ihre verteidigung hatte mildere
strafen gefordert da die angeklagten auf
befehl und unter zwang gehandelt hätten
nachdem das sogenannte sondervermögen
zur ertüchtigung der bundeswehr
grundsätzlich beschlossen ist stehen nun
erste details des wirtschaftsplans zur
umsetzung fest der größte teil soll für
die dimension luft ausgegeben werden
etwa für f-35 jets als nachfolger für
den tornado und für schwere
transporthubschrauber
außerdem sind 19,3 milliarden euro für
die marine eingeplant unter anderem für
die corvette 130 das düsseldorfer
oberlandesgericht hat fünf männer als
sie es terroristen verurteilt und bis zu
neuneinhalb jahre haft gegen sie
verhängt die taten waren als flüchtlinge
nach deutschland gekommen und lebten in
nordrhein westfalen das gericht sah es
als erwiesen an dass die islamisten auf
weisung eines kaders aus afghanistan
anschläge in deutschland verüben sollten
in nordrhein westfalen haben rund zwei
wochen nach der landtagswahl die
schwarz- grünen koalitionsverhandlungen
begonnen geleitet wurde die erste runde
von
cdu-ministerpräsident hendrik wüst und
monat neubauer von den grünen in
sondierungen hatten sich beide seiten
bereits auf den ausstieg aus der
kohleverstromung bis 2030 und ein
größeres budget für schulen und die
polizei geeinigt es wäre die erste
schwarz grüne koalition in nordrhein
westfalen
ja es ist so eine sache mit knappen
politischen mehrheiten sie
disziplinieren und zwingen zur einigkeit
aber der der auf sie angewiesen ist
steht immer im risiko sie zu verpassen
so war das heute auch bei boris rhein er
trat an zur wahl des hessischen
ministerpräsidenten schwarz grün die
regierung und nur eine stimme mehrheit
den test bestand rein und sammelte sogar
noch fünf weitere stimmen eine klare
mehrheit
nun tritt der bisherige
landtagspräsident die nachfolge von
volker bouffier an cdu grande und längst
gedienter landesvater der ein gutes jahr
vor dem wahltermin in hessen seien
schwarz grünes erbe übergibt und das
liegt derzeit ja sehr im trend peter
wagner berichtet aus wiesbaden es sind
nur ein paar schritte zu seinem neuen
arbeitsplatz für boris rhein und ehefrau
tanja der weg zur nachfolge des
hessischen cdu urgesteins volker
bouffier aber war keineswegs einfach und
vorgezeichnet 69 stimmen brauchte er 50
jährige für seine wahl 69 stimmen und
keine mehr hat schwarz grün im landtag
und hochspannung nach der auszählung auf
den vorschlag boris rhein in vielen ja
stimmen 74
mindestens fünf abgeordnete aus der
opposition entscheiden sich für boris
rhein der neue ministerpräsident bietet
allen fraktionen faire zusammenarbeit an
der blick auf die ukraine zeige dass
demokratie verteidigt werden müsse
diesmal stehen freiheitliche demokratien
autoritären regimen gegenüber meine
vision ist klar
essen sollte menschen arbeit geben
hessen soll den menschen heimat geben
und hessen soll den menschen auf
sicherheit geben damit meine ich
sicherheit in einem ganz umfassenden
sinne seit 2009 gehört der jurist rhein
zur hessischen landesregierung erst
staatssekretär unter innenminister
bouffier dann selbst innenminister mit
harter hand der mitfühlende konservative
wie er sich selbst einordnet kandidiert
2012 als oberbürgermeister in seiner
heimatstadt frankfurt und verliert gegen
den damals unbekannten peter feldmann
später wird der wissenschaftsminister
als landtagspräsident gewinnt er ab 2019
überparteilich wo es ansehen ein
wichtiger schritt auf dem weg zur
heutigen wahl
in der bildungspolitik zu wenig lehrer
bei der polizei zu wenig polizeibeamter
marode straßen bezahlbares wohnen ist in
hessen kaum möglich also die alten
baustellen die bouffier hinterlassen hat
bleiben auch für seinen nachfolger haben
jetzt wirtschaftliche herausforderungen
und wir brauchen eine aktive
wirtschaftspolitik in unserem land und
da hat natürlich mit tarek al wazir der
glaubt wirtschaftswachstum ist was
schlimmes haben wir natürlich hier den
falschen minister derzeit forscht man
natürlich jemand der progressiv
wirtschaftspolitik machen dieser wunsch
hat sich natürlich nicht erfüllt der
grüne al wazir bleibt schwarz grün hält
in hessen einzig neues gesicht im
kabinett ist das von justizminister
romantik boris rhein hat jetzt ein gutes
jahr zeit dann werden aus befreundeten
parteien gegner im nächsten wahlkampf
und wir schauen jetzt auf den
arbeitsmarkt gute nachrichten und gelang
trotz des krieges und gestörter
lieferketten steht der deutsche
arbeitsmarkt gut da das sei so
arbeitsminister heil die gute nachricht
in dieser schwierigen zeit laut
bundesagentur für arbeit waren im mai 2
millionen
260.000 menschen ohne job 50.000 weniger
als im april die quote sinkt leicht auf
4,9 prozent im vergleich zum mai vor
einem jahr sind es 400 28.000 weniger
arbeitslose dazu kommt allerdings die
sich beschleunigende
inflation die auch in der gesamten
eurozone auf einen weiteren höchststand
gestiegen ist 8,1 prozent höher als in
deutschland mit 7,9 frank bethmann das
ist keine gute nachricht auch für die
europäische zentralbank
ja generell sind das keine guten
nachrichten die preise auch jenseits der
teureren energie und der lebensmittel
steigen weiter der druck auf die ezb
nimmt zu endlich und vor allem schneller
gegenzusteuern die leitzinsen zu erhöhen
kein blatt vor dem mund haben heute der
slowakische notenbankchef die zeit des
wartens und zögerns sei vorbei wenig
verwunderlich angesichts der nackten
zahlen die inflation in europa aber auch
in den usa ist den leitzinsen inzwischen
weit enteilt ein langer weg also
steigende zinsen die preise halbwegs
irgendwann wieder einfangen werden
derartige preissprünge über 8 prozent
hatte es zuletzt in den 70er jahren
gegeben zu zeiten der damaligen ölkrise
lange war es ruhig um die inflation
jetzt ist sie zurück und droht dauerhaft
zu bleiben denn der kampf gegen krisen
und seine folgen könnte für längere zeit
die preise treiben an erster stelle zu
nennen sind da höhere ausgaben für
rüstung und klimaschutz aber auch der
fachkräftemangel und der wunsch
lieferketten zu regionalisieren dürften
das leben insgesamt teurer machen die
notenbanken für ihr zögerliches handeln
zu kritisieren ist richtig doch wahr ist
auch steigende leitzinsen sind kein
allheilmittel gegen gewisse lieferketten
kriegsfolgen oder fehlende fachkräfte
wirkt die notenbank medizin nämlich
nicht danke für den blick aufs große
ganze
frank wittmann
er galt als linker einzelkämpfer gegen
den zeitgeist der schriftsteller
friedrich christian delius der büchner
preisträger ist im alter von 79 jahren
in berlin gestorben im alter von 18
jahren veröffentlichte er erste gedichte
in werken wie als die bücher noch
geholfen haben setzte sich delius immer
wieder mit der nachkriegsgeschichte
auseinander seine romane und erzählungen
wurden in mehr als 20 sprachen übersetzt
mit den renommierten grimme-preisen
werden alljährlich herausragende
fernsehproduktionen ausgezeichnet
diesmal gehen zwei preise auch an das
zdf für die dokumentation schwarze adler
die rassismus gegen fußballer
aufarbeitet und an unsere kollegin
katrin eigendorf sie berichtet seit
jahren aus krisengebieten zurzeit immer
wieder auch aus der ukraine
die jury würdigt ihre so wörtlich
exzellenten reportagen über frauen und
mädchen in afghanistan
als besondere journalistische leistung
so toll wir gratulieren sehr herzlich
und damit sind wir schon am ende
jetzt verweisen wir sie sehr gerne an
hannes jaenicke er ist wieder im einsatz
für das wohl der tiere und beschäftigt
sich heute mit schweinen die sind
intelligenz neugierig und liebenswert
und alles andere als nur ein schnitzel
auf vier beinen lohnt sich sehr zu
schauen übrigens immer in der zdf
mediathek und später hier im programm um
0.45 unser heute-journal update mit nasa
optimieren so ist es bis morgen
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum wetter heute
abend und heute geht ja der frühling zu
ende zumindest der meteorologische mit
märz april und mai er war 1,3 grad
wärmer als die referenzperiode 1961 bis
1990 und es gab 45 prozent mehr
sonnenschein was ihn zum tritt
sonnigsten frühling seit
aufzeichnungsbeginn macht gleichzeitig
fiel aber auch ein drittel weniger regen
und damit war der frühling 2022 der
neunte zu trockene frühling in folge
immerhin gibt es ja heute nacht im
norden noch einige schauer und kurze
gewitter die etwas regen bringen auch im
süden bayerns da regnet ist das lässt
bis morgen dann aber rasch nach es wird
wieder kühler bis morgen früh bei fünf
bis elf grad bodenfrost wird jetzt aber
immer weniger wahrscheinlich
der meteorologische sommer morgen der
startet ganz unterschiedlich am ehesten
fühlte sich danach noch im süden an bei
19 bis 25 grad im norden ist es deutlich
kühler bei 15 bis 18 grad das liegt hier
eben andichten wollten die unterwegs
sind und immer wieder auch schauer und
gewitter bringen bei einem spürbaren
westlichen wind vom niederrhein bis zu
leiser aber und südlich davon bleibt es
immer häufiger trocken und richtig viel
scheint die sonne zwischen den dem
saarland und rheinland pfalz und
nordbayern erst mittags kommt dann aus
den alpen heraus wieder ein schwall mit
schauern und kurzen gewittern südlich
der donau an und zum ende der woche da
wird es aus süden immer wärmer und die
unwettergefahr steigt